-The Supreme Court ruled
that South Carolina senator
Lindsey Graham
must testify
in front of a grand jury
as part of an investigation
into Donald Trump's attempt
to steal votes in Georgia
after the 2020 election.
And yet pro-Trump
election deniers
remain undeterred
as the midterms approach.
MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell
even claimed he had access to
voting machines to detect fraud.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
You may recall that as part
of the GOP attempt
to overthrow
the election results in 2020,
Donald Trump called
Georgia Secretary of State
Brad Raffensperger
to magically find enough votes
to overturn the results
in a now-infamous phone call.
In his own separate call
with Raffensperger,
Graham asked him
if he had the power
to throw out
legally cast ballots.
At the time when the call
was first reported,
Graham described it
as an innocent conversation
and said he was just curious
about how mail voting
works in Georgia.
-What I'm very
concerned about is
that if you're gonna continue
to vote by mail
that we need to know what
systems work and what don't.
It's up to the people
of Georgia.
But I think I have every right
in the world to reach out
and say, "How does it work?"
-That's right --
He was just curious
about how mail voting works.
So instead of Googling it
or hopping on a bike
and pedaling down
to the town library,
he decided to call
an election official
right as the president
he supported was in the midst
of orchestrating a coup
to stay in power.
It's just
an innocent coincidence.
It's like how when I want to
check if my Internet is working,
I'll Google, "Is it bad that
I put my kids' college fund
into Bitcoin?"
It's a test.
I didn't actually do it, honey.
And also, if I did,
markets are fluid, so...
Graham makes it sound like
he hosts one of those podcasts
like "Radiolab"
or "Stuff You Should Know,"
where they investigate
everyday mysteries.
[ As Graham ] On today's episode
of "Tele-Graham,"
we investigate mail-in voting.
But first, this episode
is brought to you by Mailchimp,
which is what my mee-maw
used to tell me
I was gonna be when I grew up.
She said, "You ain't never
gonna be a senator.
You're gonna be working at the
post office as a mail chimp."
And I said, "That's not
even a job, Mee-Maw."
She said, "Well, they're gonna
make an exception for you,"
and I yell, "Why don't you stop
putting your carpal tunnel
sleeve in the dishwasher?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Well, anyway,
if the explanation
was as innocent
as Graham made it sound,
then you'd think
he'd have no problem
explaining that to
the Fulton County DA's office,
which is investigating attempts
to interfere
in Georgia's election
and subpoenaed Graham
as part of that investigation.
Graham sued to block
the DA's request for testimony
and took his case all the way
to the Supreme Court,
which yesterday denied Graham's
bid to block the subpoena.
-This just in --
The Supreme Court
rejected Senator
Lindsey Graham's attempt
to block the subpoena
forcing him to testify
in the 2020 election
investigation in Georgia.
-A district attorney in Georgia
had wanted Senator Graham
to appear to give his testimony
before that grand jury
November 17th.
Now the Supreme Court is saying,
you know, "We are not gonna
get you out of that."
-Damn, he couldn't even
get his bro Brett Kavanaugh
to help him out.
You guys remember
the sneer brothers.
That picture reminds me
of knocking on the screen door
at my aunt's house
and getting growled out
by her two Chihuahuas
while she took forever
to let me in.
Looked like a couple of actors
auditioning
for the role of the principal in
a gritty "Ferris Bueller" reboot
where the principal
tries to murder Ferris.
"You've stolen
your last Ferrari, Bueller."
And then Ferris would
say something like,
"You think you can kill me
and get away with it?"
And the principal would be like,
"I have two words
for you, Bueller."
-♪ Oh, yeah ♪
-We're referencing
the movies kids watch.
[ Laughter ]
Look for that gritty reboot
next year on Paramount Minus.
[ Laughter ]
So Graham will have to testify
to a grand jury
about his attempts
to help Donald Trump
overturn the 2020 election.
And yet none of this
seems to be having any effect
on Republican candidates
and officials.
They aren't deterred
by investigations into 2020.
Hundreds of Republicans
on midterm ballots
across the country, including
candidates for governor
in key swing states
like Arizona and Pennsylvania,
continue to insist the 2020
election was stolen from Trump.
And if they win,
they've made it very clear
that they will do
everything in their power
to rig future elections to
prevent Democrats from winning.
In fact, many,
including Trump himself,
are already preparing to claim
next week's midterms are rigged
if they lose.
"Rolling Stone"
has already reported
that Trump himself plans
to challenge the 2022 elections.
Oh, is Donald Trump
planning a media blitz?
His whole life has been
a media blitz.
Without the media, he'd be
selling illegal cigarettes
out of the back
of a Queens bowling alley.
How would a media blitz
look any different
from his current strategy
of appearing
on literally any right-wing
TV network or podcast,
as long as it has the words
"real," "patriot,"
or "America" in it?
This is a man who,
let's not forget,
basically had
a standing invitation
to call in to "Fox & Friends"
on a regular basis
and ramble uninterrupted
for over an hour
while the hosts just sat there
on the couch without moving
like out-of-town tourists
who accidentally wandered
into a 1970s porn theater
in Times Square.
"When they said peep show,
I thought they meant
the Easter candy."
I will say,
Kilmeade in particular
looks like a guy who wandered
into a peep show
thinking he was gonna get
some free marshmallow candies.
"Hello?
Does anyone work here?
Oh, good.
The curtain's coming up.
Hello, ma'am. I'm looking
for some candy chickens.
Ma'am, can you not hear me
through the glass?
Oh, my goodness.
Don't take your clothes off."
Just this week,
Trump called in to some random
right-wing podcast to repeat
some absolutely deranged
and completely debunked
conspiracy theories
about the horrific attack
on Nancy Pelosi's husband,
Paul Pelosi.
-It's weird things going on
in that household
in the last couple of weeks.
You know, probably you and I
are better not talking about it,
Chris.
But the glass, it seems,
was broken from the inside
to the out.
And, you know, that was --
so it wasn't a break-in.
It was a breakout.
I don't know.
You know, you hear
the same things I do.
-Yeah, the 911 tape
seems to suggest
that he knew
the identity of the guy.
-Yeah. Yeah, that's a --
that's a lot of bad stuff.
I'm not a fan of Nancy Pelosi,
but what's going on there
is very sad.
-No big deal, everybody.
Just the former president
of the United States
saying weird things
have been going on
in the Pelosi household
for the last couple of weeks,
which I guess he knows because
what, he's the [bleep] Watcher?
[ Laughter ]
You know, it takes
a real sack of [bleep]
to start gaming out a way
you can make
an 82-year-old attempted murder
victim the bad guy.
Trump just makes [bleep] up
and spreads it through
vague Mafia-style innuendo
like he's in a deleted scene
from "The Sopranos."
[ As Trump ]
It's very sad what's going on
over at the place.
Over at the place by the thing
with our friend.
[ Normal voice ] And, you know,
as bad as it is sometimes,
you know, I will admit I have
the urge to fight fire with fire
and do the same thing to Trump.
You know, just spread some
completely made-up accusation
about him, like, you know,
I don't know --
You didn't hear it from me,
but there's some very weird
things going on
in Trump's household, like...
[ Laughter ]
I hear his head is shrinking.
He hides it.
[ Laughter ]
He hides it
when he goes out in public
by wearing a giant fake head
on top of his real tiny head.
And look, I'm no fan of Trump,
but it's very -- it's very sad.
It's very sad
what's happening.
I mean, you see
the same pictures I see.
Doctors, I guess they have to
fill his head up with helium
before every speech
to make it look normal.
And that's why his voice
gets really high sometimes,
you know, like this.
-[ High-pitched voice ] You
never stop fighting for America.
And I will never,
ever stop fighting for you.
-It's very sad. Very sad.
It's very weird.
And, you guys, this has been
"Seth Spreads a Baseless Rumor
About Donald Trump."
Anyway, the point is,
Trump and his movement,
which now includes Republicans
running in close races
across country this year,
are preparing to steal both
the upcoming midterm elections
and eventually,
if they regain power,
the presidential election
in 2024.
In Arizona, armed right-wingers
inspired by the lies
of Arizona's Republican
candidates for governor,
Kari Lake, and secretary
of state, Mark Finchem,
have been loitering
near early voting drop boxes
to intimidate those voters.
And "The New York Times"
just reported
that MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell,
whose phone was recently seized
in a Hardee's drive-through
by the FBI as part
of an investigation
into an illegal
voting machine breach
by a pro-Trump
county clerk in Colorado,
is actually using his business
to fuel the election
denial movement.
He's the single largest
advertiser on Fox News.
He finances a large network
of right-wing media outlets,
and he spent as much
as $40 million
on conferences,
activist networks,
a digital media platform,
legal battles and researchers
that promote his theory.
I'm honestly shocked
he even has $40 million
to throw around
on [bleep] like this.
Did nobody have a pillow
before he showed up?
Did he invent them?
Was everyone just laying
their head down
on a cinder block every night?
Then he came along and said,
"Imagine if that cinder block
was just a little bit softer."
I mean, I'm 48.
I think I bought a new pillow
like twice in my life.
But they're just flying
out the door at MyPillow
because what, this guy
seems well-rested?
He has the energy
of a guy being dragged
out of a Buffalo Wild Wings
in Duluth
for stuffing barbecue sauce
in his pockets.
And who are these researchers?
Are they just a bunch
of other middle-aged guys
with mustaches
and Midwest accents
screaming back and forth
at each other?
"Mike, you're never gonna
believe what I found here.
I hacked into the voting system
and found
a whole bunch of fraud."
"Great work, Paul.
I'm still sifting
through the mail ballots,
looking for signatures
that don't match.
How about you, Steve?"
"I'm filling my head up
with helium
to keep it from deflating.
I got da Trump disease."
Anyway...
this is a man
who had his phone taken away
by the FBI
in a Hardee's drive-through,
and he was an early and
prominent backer of Kari Lake,
the pro-Trump candidate
who is now leading the polls
for Arizona governor.
And in a deranged rant
this week,
Lindell even said
that he and his team
would be monitoring every vote
across the country.
-I'm telling everyone out there,
we are watching
from every angle.
There's people in every state,
every county, every precinct.
We have cyber guys
watching this.
I looked at a thing today.
It was on my Twitter
back from November of 2020,
and they showed CNN,
20,000 votes dropping right off
of Donald Trump's total
in real time.
You guys,
votes don't go in reverse.
These are computer
manipulation algorithms.
So what I'm telling you
is this election, it's all eyes.
We have all the camera angles.
-"We're watching
from every angle.
It's all eyes.
We have all the camera angles."
Somehow the MyPillow guy
has turned himself into Jigsaw.
Although I'm not sure
I believe you
when you say you have all eyes
and all camera angles
since, you know,
you don't even have a phone.
But if that's true,
it's probably not a good idea
to be publicly confessing
that you've somehow
hacked into voting machines
when you're under
active investigation by the FBI.
First they took his phone
at a Hardee's drive-through.
Next, they'll probably
confiscate all his cameras
while he's in line
at a Carl's Jr.
[ As Lindell ] I'm never gonna
get that burger.
[ Normal voice ]
But I will say,
I did enjoy
his little impression
of computer manipulation
algorithms, whatever those are.
Can we see that again?
-These are computer
manipulation algorithms.
-Does he think
that's how you type?
That's not how you type.
That's how a 19th-century
English dandy
chooses a candy
from a silver platter.
"Ooh-hoo-hoo-hoo-hoo!
Ohh-oh-oh
Oh, a Charleston Chew.
Don't mind if I do."
The GOP might be talking a lot
about crime or inflation
or culture war issues.
But this is the beating heart
of Trumpism
in the modern Republican Party.
They simply do not accept
the legitimacy
of elections they don't win.
And if they gain power
next week,
they will absolutely
use that power
to rig future elections
for Trump
or any other
Republican candidate.
If they could,
they would look at all the votes
in an election
against Donald Trump,
take all the names,
and turn them into...
-All eyes.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
Can't win them all.
This has been "A Closer Look."
The midterm elections
are coming up.
So to make sure that you're good
to vote in this election,
visit our good friends
at headcount.org
to check your voter
registration status
or to register to vote.